in South Florida the cars stretched out
for nearly two miles as thousands of
people waited for hours to reach their
local food bank the same thing happened
in California Pennsylvania and New York
City food banks across the u.s. are
seeing a massive rise in the number of
residents in need because of coronavirus
but on American farms the economic
fallout from the corona virus looks very
different here it's led to a widespread
surplus of food that's gone to waste
millions of pounds of perfectly good
potatoes cucumbers and squash left to
rot or plowed back into the fields and
dairy farmers forced to dump millions of
gallons of fresh milk down the drain
it's all because of a break in the food
supply chain one that for now means we
have farmers with too much food and very
few options where the farmers out here
we're all in this together
and there's something don't change Sue
and we're going down to understand why
the food supply chain is broken let's
look at milk a very simplified supply
chain for dairy products in the u.s.
looks something like this it starts with
cows and a dairy farm where they're
milked that milk is filled into tanks
and then sent to processors there it
turns into products like pasteurized
fluid milk cheese yogurt or butter
it's then packaged and sent off to
grocery stores where consumers can get
their dairy off the shelves but here's
the thing even though a large portion of
dairy production is aimed at grocery
stores it's just one of many places
where the product ends up about half of
all production is aimed at other avenues
like schools and businesses Starbucks
for example typically goes through
hundreds of thousands of gallons of milk
every day together all of these avenues
amount to a huge amount of No
production in the u.s. about 218 billion
pounds in 2019 every part of dairy
production from farming to processing
and packaging carries out a specialized
process which makes the supply chain
efficient under normal circumstances but
as the coronavirus started to spread and
the nation began to shut down this chain
started to look a lot different schools
and restaurants canceled orders but the
cows at the farm still needed to be
milked
a significant drop in demand from these
avenues led to way more supply but
there's nowhere to send that surplus
even though more people have been buying
dairy at grocery stores during lockdown
the system isn't built to redirect
excess supply that easily we want to get
food to the people who need it and we're
trying but when you have a really
specialized industry it doesn't
necessarily translate that's because the
same dairy products meant for schools
businesses and grocery stores look very
different after they're processed and
packaged for example at grade schools
they might take the shape of small milk
cartons made for kids or massive bags of
cheese for food service companies to
make lunches at a restaurant the
products might be large five gallon
containers of milk or 40 pound blocks of
cheese and at grocery stores there are
the products we're more used to seeing
like single gallon cartons of milk and
small packages of cheese converting
those school milk cartons into something
that people will actually buy at grocery
stores would be a massive change
facilities often don't have the right
packaging to make a switch while other
products like a large block of cheese
would need to be cut to a more
manageable size for consumers meaning
millions of dollars in new equipment
that many processors can't afford you
can't deliver a 500-pound barrel to
someone's house and be like here's your
cheese I mean you have entire plants
built for school milk for kids we could
have just sent crates of Malcolm what
parents may like here's your crates from
the school
feed your kid where are they gonna store
it in their fridges what we have from
restaurants and from food service just
doesn't neatly turn into something
that's usable for the average person at
home we're switching as fast as we can
but this is unprecedented right
some are sending their surplus product
to food banks but these organizations
often don't have the refrigerator
capacity or the manpower needed to
distribute so much perishable product
and even with shifts in some production
from businesses and schools to grocery
stores the new consumer demand likely
wouldn't make up for the huge losses
from these other avenues that extra
supply leads to an incredible amount of
food waste we started dumping milk March
31st and we dumped seven semi loads of
milk a day which is 42,000 gallons of
milk a day we dumped for about two weeks
when you think about a semi load like
the big tanker trucks you would see out
on the interstate that hundreds of
trucks that size you don't have that
food getting to people that's crushed
this food supply chain problem has led
to a massive drop in milk prices which
started to tumble just as the
coronavirus took hold in the US
December's milk was 24 bucks today it's
1080 I don't care if you're milking 10
cows or 5,000 it don't matter
10 dollars and 80 cents is not gonna pay
the bills my organic milk is very
expensive it's expensive to make it's
expensive to market what happens to my
milk is it gets marketed as conventional
milk which is basically about half of
what I get paid it doesn't take much of
a math scientist to figure out that
you're really in trouble that drop is
just the latest in several years of
record low prices for the dairy industry
since 2015 milk prices paid to farmers
have been well below the cost of
production factors like a rise in
corporate farming trade wars that
decreased us
and more people choosing milk
alternatives have led to too much dairy
and low prices it's also led to a dairy
farming crisis in 2014 there were about
45,000 dairy farms in the US but over
the next five years
11,000 dairy farms shut down that's 9 US
dairy farms lost every day during that
period that number is likely to increase
even more because of coronavirus today
many dairy cooperatives often made up of
hundreds of different farms are taking
this hit together by sharing the burden
and making sure not every farm has to
dump their milk many have enacted quotas
to keep production at a level that's
more in line with what they predict can
be sold some are suggesting farmers sell
off cows and others are incentivizing
farmers to leave their businesses
entirely we have to cut back 10 percent
of our milk
we are selling cows we're drying up cows
early we're trying to do whatever we can
now to drop our production 10% but it's
going to be tough the US government has
allocated payouts for farmers to cover
some of these losses and they have set
aside money for government purchases of
dairy and other fresh produce for food
banks these provisions could be one way
to tackle both the hardships of farmers
and the growing hunger crisis that
affects millions of Americans but while
it may be a good first step many in the
industry warned that it could
disproportionately help large corporate
farms and fall short of getting small
farmers the help they need immediately
as those things run out who knows what's
going to happen and that's the
uncertainty that I feel I think most
other people feel it we need to have a
better plan the unprecedented amount of
extra milk has forced some farmers and
processors to think about other
solutions too like lobbying Pizza chains
to put more cheese on pizzas or lobbying
for a more controversial long-term
solution like setting federal limits
on the amount of milk production across
the country so that the supply and the
prices will always be stable we need
some help out here and how we're gonna
get it I don't know but if we don't get
it we're all in big trouble what's
happening with the supply chain in the
US isn't just a problem for dairy it's a
problem for farmers across the country
who have seen their demands diminish
from schools and restaurants and whether
it's milk or green beans for farmers
trashing their produce isn't just a
financial blow it's also an emotional
one we work so hard to provide for other
people that's what our calling is that's
why we do this we're not doing it for
the money that's for sure and so to see
what we provide go to waste is just been
really devastating
[Music]